hello everybody
it's a crappy diagram that screws with
Uncle Sam the United Nations Secretary
General has published a new report to
tackle so-called misinformation online
as you may recall misinformation means
anything a leftist doesn't want to hear
in the 25-page document un Chief Antonio
guterres Advocates that the world must
address the spread of hate speech myths
and dis information on the internet I
wonder if he thinks the proliferation of
hate and lies in the digital space is
causing grave Global harm
the proliferation of hate and lies in
the digital space is causing grave
Global harm now
it is full in Conflict deaths and
destruction now
it is threatening democracy and human
rights now
no surprise check this out the most
interesting thing in the report is this
baffling bizarre Venn diagram he chose
to illustrate his lack of a point I
haven't seen a drawing this misleading
since Jessica Rabbit
rabbits do not look like that
I told the cops everything
let's see here we have misinformation
meets disinformation combined with hate
speech equals pollutes the information
ecosystem and threatens human progress
what
remember kids those are all subjective
terms obviously legislating their
definitions at the recommendation of a
global authoritarian is the fast track
to 1984. Gutierrez proposes a global
code of conduct that would see
governments and tech companies policing
content without infringing on Free
Speech which is like cutting off your
oxygen without infringing on your
breathing
but hey why let the U.N have all the
dumb fun we can make stupid graphs too
for example when you combine ripped plus
handsome plus intelligent
yeah you get Hammer huh women's restroom
men's restroom White House lawn equals
places Joe Biden has defecated
microphone booze
Xanax
Kamala Harris
this is such a good game show
you right it should be called Venn
diagram anger
stupidity
flatulence
The View
I have to copyright this
Mother Teresa George Clooney
Brad Pitt Greg Gutfeld
we knew that was coming Fox Nation new
game show Venn diagram I'm hosting it
now I should take it to a network or
something make some money
Charlie
why why is he doing this what are the
intentions it's the U.N yeah well you
know for all we want to complain about
influencers and uh and and focus on the
unseemly side of the internet the the
bottom line is you know the internet uh
social media is the most amazing uh
mechanism for speaking truth to power
and uh and I I don't think that in a lot
of ways we've sort of recognized this
because we're spending so much time
focusing on weirdos on the south lawn
lifting up their shirts but it is a
powerful powerful tool and of course all
this is for you know since the beginning
of time you have the U.N Secretary
General who is threatened by this and so
they have to they have to describe
everything with all their orwellian
terms like hate speech and
disinformation but all they want to do
is they want to stop it because it's a
threat to their power and a threat to
their money and uh and so that's you
know that's what this is all about cat I
wonder how much that chart cost
you know like the UN probably paid 200
grand for that and we probably paid for
it I could have done that for 10 bucks I
do a lot of things for 10 bucks cat you
know that all of that's true yes
um yeah I don't know why they bother but
they don't really do anything they just
sit around and like eat a bunch of
lunches right right that's what they do
they do and then they they cause traffic
and they sit around they sit around and
eat lunch and they use our Vital sex
workers
I think it's I I don't think they mind
that's what that's what they do for work
yes uh although when they talk about
human rights and this and that I think
that a very Key Human right is the right
to free speech and the right to be able
to express yourself freely and as you
pointed out all of these things are
subjective and I don't want anybody who
sits around and just eats lunch all day
to be deciding what is acceptable versus
not acceptable for me or for anyone else
to say um
Tyrus do you think the sex workers is a
tax write-off yeah
you know I think I think when they act
like lying just showed up in 2023 like
what people have been fully forever so
all of a sudden now we need a chart you
can pretty much tell with somebody and
the U.N has been leading the world and
being what they want is they want no one
to fact check them or call them out like
I think we learned in covid you got to
start asking questions okay because if
we just followed one Survivor awesome
yes but that's what this is this is and
misinformation and disinformation is the
same thing okay it's the same thing okay
what threatens human progress is the
fact that you are elected to do this job
and that's the best you came up with we
had the world's greatest got together
and they couldn't figure out to make and
plus why would you have the same
different shades of blue I'm colorblind
this is confusing
the only thing I make out here is
threatens
hate it's all hey speech disinformation
misinformation can go in the same bubble
there you go it could just be one book
well I don't like one ball but yeah it
didn't work Jim it was like they tried
to conflate opinions with falsehoods
what is your rating on this you're an
expert on Venn diagrams in fact I think
you majored at uh at Yale and in Venn
diagram right yes exactly yes I was I
was unfortunately I didn't graduate I
was caught masturbating in the cafeteria
I mean the lunch was phenomenal my
highest praise
um but I think this is obviously just
very silly
um I I am particularly not good
informing my own opinion so I'm always
helped uh that happened to have somebody
uh tell me what's good and what's not
yes I don't trust the UN though I think
Twitter should be the ultimate Authority
and the people that work for Twitter and
their definition the reason that what
they said I read a lot of this
um and they said the difference between
misinformation and disinformation was
intent like misinformation is a mistake
whereas disinformation was a purposeful
thing that's their definition of it
right I just think that they needed
something to fill the third circle yeah
that's true that's true they needed
balance but it really it's it's
interesting it's not to add Clarity at
all it's confused you because
ultimately underneath all those words is
a bad idea let's just say what hate
speech yeah exactly I posted a photo of
myself and people were critical of my
appearance yeah
that is hate speech thank you very much
but so was that picture yes it was yes
tough crowd tonight I know I know it's
but Tuesdays are always like this
they're you know they're coming back
from a long weekend yeah they thought
they were going to a game show that up
here hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else